Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zur Ligatour. Heute geht es wieder um die 2. Liga. Ihr könnt euch freuen auf eine tolle Sendung moderiert wieder von Eva. Warum hört ihr mich? Vielleicht habt ihr es schon eine Ahnung. Unsere Kontoverbindung wird sich ändern. Ist nicht unsere Entscheidung, ist ein bisschen tricky für uns, denn jetzt müssen sich alle Daueraufträge von euch auch ändern, damit der Rasenfunk weiter Paywall-Werbe und Sponsoren frei bleiben kann. Das Ganze wird relativ bald geschehen. Wir werden voraussichtlich morgen am 19. März die neue Kontoverbindung erhalten und dann sagen wir auch über alle Kanäle, die wir haben, euch SupporterInnen Bescheid. Was ihr aber jetzt schon tun könnt, um auch wirklich mitzubekommen, auf welches Konto ihr dann euren Dauerauftrag bitte in Zukunft umstellt, ist euch als SupporterInnen zu registrieren. Einfach auf rasenfunk.de gehen und dann im Menü rechts oben eine Registrierung abschließen. Das bedeutet einfach nur, dass wir eure E-Mail-Adresse bekommen. Keine Angst, wir werden euch nicht zuspämmen. Da bekommt man im Schnitt so ein bis zweimal pro Jahr eine E-Mail. Und aber auf jeden Fall auch morgen oder die Tage dann, wenn wir die neue E-Bahn haben, bekommt er diese Informationen. Wir hoffen, dass dieser Umschwung nicht zu sehr den Rasenfunk schadet, denn da gehen immer ein paar SupporterInnen verloren. Aber deswegen ja diese Aufsager. Bitte registriert euch als SupporterInnen und jetzt geht es los mit der Sendung. Viel Spaß euch!
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben.
Rossi zu kurz ab, wär lang genug für Gili Landgraf.
Wagner, Martin Wagner. Und das 1 zu 0.
Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl.
Alexander Schur! Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, ich hoffe, die Verwirrung, die hat sich so langsam gelegt und ihr seid schon dran gewöhnt, jetzt mich zu sehen beziehungsweise zu hören. Ich bin Eva Lottabohle und freue mich recht herzlich, euch zu einer neuen Ligatour zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer begrüßen zu dürfen. Und keine Sorge, in zwei Wochen sitzt auch Marc wieder hier. Ich habe mich für den März hier in sämtlichen Formaten ein bisschen breit gemacht. Da müsst ihr jetzt durch. Glücklicherweise wird das ganze Jahr aber durch unsere Gäste auch keine One-Woman-Show. Aber bevor ich die hier auch offiziell in der Runde begrüße, gibt es wie immer den wichtigen Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich ausschließlich durch eure Spenden. Und lieben Dank an alle, die bereits Rasenfunk-SupporterInnen sind. Die, die es noch nicht sind, vielleicht mal drüber nachdenken, welche zu werden. Und ganz wichtig natürlich auch dran denken an die Kontoumstellung ab morgen oder je nachdem, wann ihr das hier hört. Der Dank stellvertretend für alle bereits registrierten SupporterInnen geht heute an Haini, Jovel Stefan, David Hammerson, Andri, Gummi und Damian. Vielen Dank für eure Unterstützung. So, das war jetzt aber genug Housekeeping. Ich freue mich jetzt, den ersten Gast in der Runde begrüßen zu dürfen. Und er ist Teil des Fortuna-Podcasts Aus dem Exil. Und ich glaube, nach fünf Jahren, wenn ich richtig nachgeguckt habe, das erste Mal wieder bei uns im Rasenfunk zu Gast. Hallo Jan!
Hallo zusammen. Das letzte Mal, als ich hier war, da ging es um Corona. Und was Fortuna in der Corona-Pause macht, so lange ist es her. Und ich habe über Corona-Lieder gesprochen, die die Fortuna in dieser Zeit aufgenommen hat. Und das haben wir alles vergessen. Zum Glück.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, also dahin möchten wir glaube ich alle nicht zurück.
Nein.
Um das Trio perfekt zu machen, darf ich jemandem begrüßen, der in dieser Saison schon mal die Ehre hatte, hier über seinen FC Schalke zu sprechen. Dominik Slišković ist mal wieder dabei. Hallo Dominik. Schön, dass wir immer wieder gemeinsam beim Fußball sprechen dürfen.
Glück auf in die Runde. Freut mich auch und bin sehr gespannt, in welche Richtung ich heute über den FC Schalke plaudern und schwadronieren darf.
Ja, gespannt sind wir da auf jeden Fall alle. Aber bevor wir da jetzt in die Tiefe gehen, bei eurem beiden Verein wollen wir natürlich einen Blick auf die Lage der Liga geben oder werfen, wie ihr das kennt. Und ich fange da ausnahmsweise mal ganz, ganz kurz an, und zwar mit einem Hannover Update. Ihr habt alle drauf gewartet und saßt bestimmt genauso auf glühenden Kohlen wie ich. Gestern konnten die Lizensierungsunterlagen doch noch fristgerecht eingereicht werden, dem Hannover 96 droht zumindest laut deren Vorgaben kein Absturz in die Regionalliga. Am Sonntagabend war dann nämlich endlich klar, die Management-GMBA, aka der Aufsichtsrat, die haben sich auf eine Neubesetzung der Geschäftsführung geeinigt, die ja diese Lizens- oder Lizensierungsunterlagen unterschreiben müssen. Markus Mann, der ist Geschäftsführer Sport bis 2029 ab sofort, und Henning Binsus, der ist der kaufmännische Geschäftsführer bis 2027. Das ist jetzt enorm runtergebrochen. Wer nochmal nachhören will, was da denn jetzt eigentlich los war, kann gerne nochmal in die Folge von nur zwei Wochen reinhören. Hört sich nochmal etwas anders an, wenn man nicht weiß, oder wenn man jetzt weiß, wie es ausgeht. Aber das war auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, Allanova-Fans haben danach erstmal 48 Stunden lang durchgeschlafen. Ich glaube, das war nicht so ganz entspannt. Aber Dominik, es gibt ja nicht nur Hannover 96 in dieser Liga. Was ist dir denn sonst noch so aufgefallen?
Ja, ich als Münsterländer habe natürlich mit Wohlwollen registriert, dass der SC Preuß Münster in Elbersberg sicherlich die Überraschungsmannschaft der Zweitligasaison dreifach punkten konnte, dass Simon Scherda, Fußballgott, schon sein zweites Zweitligator geschossen hat. Für alle, die es vielleicht nicht so auf dem Schirm haben, Simon Scherda ist, glaube ich, seit der Kreidezeit beim SC Preuß Münster also alles mitgemacht mit diesem Verein, was ja in den letzten 15 Jahren möglich war und hätte mir jemand vor vier, fünf Jahren gesagt, Simon Scherda wird irgendwann mal Zweitliga-Stammspieler und auch noch zweifacher Torschütze. Wenn er SC Preuß Münster sein hätte, ich dem Vogel gezeigt. Von daher auch eine schöne romantische Geschichte für alle, die sagen, ja, diese Homegrown-Player und One-Club-Man und so, die sterben alle aus. Nein, im Münsterland, im beschaulichen Münster gibt es das noch in Form von Simon Scherda. Und ja, Preußen hält sich immer noch über den Strich, also nicht nur über den Strich der direkten Abstiegsplätze, sondern auch über den Relegationsstrich. Stand ja auch nach dem Sieg in Elbersberg sogar noch vor der Hertha aus Berlin. Die haben dann ja eindrucksvoll die Eintracht aus Braunschweig abgeschossen im Eintrachtsstadion. Aber ich glaube, wenn Preußen jetzt am Ende der Saison auf 15 Platz steht, wird da keiner drum trauern, sondern da könnten die sehr zurückhaltenden Münsteraner und Münsterländer, glaube ich, auch mal ein wenig aus sich rauskommen.
Und man wäre natürlich der einzige Aussteiger, der auch an seinem Trainer festgehalten hat. Weil nicht nur bei Regensburg, das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen her, gab es einen Trainerwechsel, sondern auch bei Ulm, das ist dann letztes Jahr passiert, im Wörle entlassen. Das sorgte für, ich glaube harmlos ausgedrückt, ziemlich viel Gegenwind. Also wenn man da so ein bisschen quergelesen hat bei den sozialen Medien, was da so unter dem Post dann Kommentare gab. Also da wurde, glaube ich, nicht nur einmal die geistige Verfassung der Verantwortlichen bei SSV Ulm in Frage gestellt. Aber muss ich sagen, jetzt unter dem neuen Trainer, ich glaube Lechleiter, ich meine, wenn ich es richtig gelesen habe, kam der von der U19, der jetzt übernommen hat. Der hat zumindest schon mal einen Punkt in Karlsruhe geholt und da kann man natürlich diskutieren, ob das an einem sehr, sehr harmlosen Karlsruhe lag oder an einem stabil stehenden Ulm war. Sicherlich beides, aber genau noch zur Vollständigkeit halber. Also Münster hat eben 6 Punkte Vorsprung auf Ulm, auf 17 und 10 Punkte auf Regensburg. Also das sieht auf jeden Fall ganz gut aus. Und ich weiß, in dem neu gegründeten Forumstread auf mitmachen.rasenfunk wurde auch ein neuer Münster Schwerpunkt gewünscht. Werden wir sicherlich bald auch wieder liefern können, um dann noch mal tiefer darauf einzugehen, was denn jetzt der Schlüssel zum Erfolg ist quasi.
Vielleicht einer der Schlüssel der Erfolge, tatsächlich Sascha Hildmann nicht mit anderen Vereinen gesprochen hat, sowie Wörle, ja, offenbar. Was ja dann zum Verhängnis geworden ist in Ulm, wenn man auch da ein bisschen die Medien quer liest.
Ja, ich glaube, ausschlaggebend ist, dass Hoeneß irgendwie zu Leipzig gehen könnte und deshalb...
Ja, das ist eine komplette Verstrickung. Also Quasenjog soll nach Stuttgart, weil Hoeneß zu Leipzig und dann sollte Wörle nach......
zu Paderborn....
Paderborn. Und genau, also wie so oft liegt das übel in Leipzig. Das ist jetzt auch so in Ulm angekommen.
Ja, ich stelle mir gerade vor, so wie all... also oder ich würde mir das so vorstellen, dieses Meme aus Always Sunny in Philadelphia, glaube ich, vor diesem Board mit diesen roten Linien, dieses Meme, diese Verstreckungen. Es ist so, so stelle ich mir das vor, so das passiert und deshalb unter dieser Domino, dieses Domino Stein Meme. So stelle ich mir das ein bisschen vor. Jan, du hattest im Vorgespräch schon mal gesagt, für dich gibt es zumindest an einem Tabellenende so langsam so ein kleines Trio, was sich rauskristallisiert.
Ja, also das ist ja die Liga der Momentaufnahmen. Das habt ihr ja vor zwei Wochen schon festgestellt. Das ist ja auch ganz schön. Und so kann man sich aus dem Fenster lehnen und irgendwie was konstatieren, was in drei, vier Wochen eventuell auch schon wieder Essig ist. Aber ich würde sogar sagen, dass es kein Trio, sondern ein Quartett ist. Die ersten vier, würde ich schon jetzt in dem Moment, in dem wir uns befinden, schon als eine Gruppe sehen, die es am ehesten schaffen könnten, unter die ersten zwei oder die ersten drei Plätze zu kommen. Der HSV, wirklich sehr überzeugend die letzten Wochen, haben dann nicht nur die Fortuna sehr souverän 4-1 geschlagen, sondern auch noch das Glück des Tüchtigen ein wenig gegen Magdeburg, denn ausgerechnet in dem Spiel, wo Selke gesperrt ist, wo Glatzel noch nicht wieder auftrumpfen kann, noch verletzt ist oder eingewechselt werden muss am Ende oder konnte am Ende, spielt man eben in Magdeburg und da kann man halt mit Königsdörfer dessen Stärken voll ausspielen, beispielsweise in Magdeburg, die eben auch Ballbesitz haben und sich eben nicht hinten reinstellen. Das hätte vielleicht für den HSV anders ausgesehen, wenn man gegen Hannover gespielt hätte, die halt anders auftreten und dann hat man eben den tiefen Kader, um das zu ermöglichen und vielleicht auch das Glück in dem Moment, weil einige der Tore, die dann für den HSV zählten, ja auch aus Magdeburger Unzulänglichkeiten oder Unaufmerksamkeiten entstehen. Aber das ist halt so. HSV macht sehr guten Eindruck und auch die anderen drei finde ich. Beim FC bin ich mir noch nicht ganz sicher. Die haben immer so Potenzial, so ein bisschen unruhig zu werden. Aber auch bei Lautern und bei Paderborn habe ich das Eindruck, die bei Paderborn, der Trainer hat immer einen Plan. Der muss nicht immer aufgehen. Kann auch mal schief gehen, aber das ist halt so. Aber immer hat er einen. Und das ist, glaube ich, in dieser Liga schon mal ein Pluspunkt. Und auch das führt eben zu wilden Kicks, wie am Wochenende zwischen Paderborn und Karls Lautern. Karls Lautern hat einen starken Kader und die sehe ich auch eben oben dabei. Also wenn man da eine Gruppe bilden möchte. Dahinter wird es dann ein bisschen schwieriger. Also Magdeburg traue ich es nicht so ganz zu, auch wenn ich den wünschen würde, dass so ein risikoreiches Offensivkonzept auch mal aufgeht und belohnt wird. Und auch bei den anderen, über Hannover 96 habt ihr es schon gesprochen, über die Fortuna werden wir noch sprechen. Und auch bei Elbersberg, ich kann es mir nicht so ganz vorstellen, die Leistungsträger jung. Das kann am Ende auch ein bisschen die eine oder andere Richtung ausgehen. Da weiß ich noch nicht genau, was ich davon halten soll. Aber aktuell, denke ich, gibt es– und das ist vielleicht etwas, was in den letzten Wochen nicht immer so klar war– schon eben 1, 2, in meiner Sicht 4 Mannschaften, die sich sehr darum bewerben, in den nächsten Wochen eben den Aufstiegskampf zu prägen. Es kann in dieser Liga natürlich alles passieren. Und irgendwer kann mit zwei Spielen irgendwo in den Topf greifen oder eben auch in die Scheiße. Und dann ist das jetzt auch wieder anders aus. Aber ich finde, es spricht schon ein bisschen was für die zwei bis vier Mannschaften um.
Dominik, gehst du mit?
Ja, ich sehe auch den HSV als gesichert in den Top 3, wobei das wahrscheinlich ihnen jetzt am Ende das Genick brechen wird. Das wünsche ich ihnen nicht. Also ich glaube, sieben Jahre Zweitliga reichen dann jetzt auch wirklich für den HSV. Ich will auch, dass so ein Verein belohnt wird, jetzt auf Merlin Pulzin gesetzt zu haben, ihm die Verantwortung nicht nur integrientweise übertragen zu haben, sondern an ihn zu glauben in seinem ganzen Konzept. Wir hatten Merlin Pulzin jetzt vor einigen Wochen auch in der Ed Broski Show zu Gast und man merkt einfach, wenn man mit ihm auch spricht, dass er weiß bzw. ganz genau weiß, was für Personen er vor sich hat und wie er sie ansprechen muss. Und ich glaube, das ist so ein Soft-Skill, den er eben beim HSV sehr gut einbringen kann. Also Spieler, die vielleicht dazu neigen, eher nervös zu werden, wenn es mal nicht läuft, anders anzusprechen als Leute, die du eher runterbremsen musst, weil sie so vor Selbstbewusstsein strotzen. Da denke ich an Davies Elke zum Beispiel, bei dem ja auch niemand gedacht hätte, dass er so durch die Decke geht in dieser Saison. Also er war eher als Backup eingeplant, wurde wie so oft viel belacht und jetzt ist er auf sehr, sehr gutem Weg dorthin, Torschützenkönig der 2. Liga zu werden. Also selbst wenn jetzt Moussa Silla, um schon mal einen kurzen Vorgriff auf Schalke zu machen, zurückkommt, glaube ich nicht, dass er diesen Gap von, ich glaube, aktuell 4 Toren auf Davies Elke nochmal einholt. Also es ist wirklich sehr beeindruckend, wie auch dann es Polzin geschafft hat, das Spiel auch nochmal auf Elke zuzuschneiden, als Zielspieler, als jemand, der auch Bälle festmachen kann, dass vielleicht da der eine oder andere Ball weniger in die Tiefe kommt, weil er jetzt vielleicht nicht so sehr über den Antrieb kommt, wie zum Beispiel Königsdörfer, was eben, wie Jan gesagt hat, gegen Magdeburg dann wiederum gut in den Matchplan eingebaut wurde, dass man da die Lücken oder die Vorwärtsbewegungen von Magdeburg gegen sie nutzt und Königsdörfer eben schnell in die Schnittstellen hineinläuft. Von daher, das sieht schon sehr nach einem in sich greifenden Konzept aus und Ähnliches sehe ich eher sogar noch in Paderborn, wobei mich in Paderborn einfach die Art Fußball zu spielen begeistert, weil es halt so einen alten Thomas Schaaf-Touch hat von lieber eben beispielsweise 5-3 gewinnen als 1-0 und Vazenok ist ja auch so ein positiv verrückter Typ, also wirklich ein Typ, der sowohl in der Außendarstellung als auch sicherlich im täglichen Training den Tanz auf dem Drahtseil hinlegt und auch seine eigenen Grenzen, die Grenzen seiner Spieler, der der Öffentlichkeit ausprobiert. Und das ist, glaube ich, gerade bei so einem Standort wie Paderborn gar nicht so verkehrt. Also ich glaube, für Paderborn wäre so ein aseptischer Trainer, der total in sich gekehrt ist. So ein Lucien Favre wäre das Schlimmste, was ihm passieren könnte. Jemand, der super sozusagen am Schreibtisch ist und das vielleicht auch vermitteln kann in Gesprächen, aber halt so eine Mannschaft und so ein Umfeld nicht anzündet. Und wie gesagt, eben bei so einem doch kleineren und ja auch nicht unbedingt in dem Sinne traditionsreichen Standort wie Paderborn ist es dann schon auch ganz gut, dass da einfach jemand ist, der den Spielern so eine positive Beklopptheit mitgibt und auch so einen Bock auf Fußballspielen vermittelt.
Ja, da gehe ich mit. Und das ist natürlich, also ist natürlich auch ein Verdienst der Arbeit, die in Paderborn geleistet wird, dass man sie da oben immer wieder, naja, unterschätzt und nicht mit reinrechnet, aber sie ja eigentlich auch nie wirklich was seit, also nach diesen vielen Jahren des Hin- und Herrs, also immer dieses Platz 2 oder Platz 18, ja eigentlich, ja so eine gewisse Konstanz in den Top, ja man kann ja sagen 25 gefunden haben in Deutschland. Das ist natürlich schon so ein, ja, also auf jeden Fall auch ein Prädikat, was man irgendwie mitbringt. Und da haben sie es jetzt in den letzten Jahren geschafft, sich eben da das zu erarbeiten. Und das ist natürlich auch ein enorm wichtiges Fundament. Auch wenn ich also dann immer gespannt bin, weil man dann ja schon sieht, dass dann der, ich sag mal der Gap zur Bundesliga und des Erfolgsfalls in der Bundesliga ist dann ja meistens doch zu groß, weil es dann halt eben nicht dafür reicht, diesen Standort dann quasi mal über eine Saison hinaus in der Bundesliga zu halten. Ähnlich auch jetzt mit Darmstadt oder so. Also da brauchst du glaube ich schon irgendwie mal einen ganz guten Mix, um das dann auch zu schaffen. Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob sie das im Falle eines Aufstiegs und dann natürlich auch die ganzen Gerüchte rund um Quasniok, die dann auch in den letzten Wochen und Monaten mit IHand einhergingen, so rum ist die Wortwahl, ob sie das dann schaffen. Aber das werden wir spätestens Ende Mai wissen, wie es da auch weitergeht und ob das überhaupt eine Diskussion wird für den Sommer. Wie es sowieso Ende Mai aussieht in der Tabelle, das würde Fortuna Düsseldorf sicherlich auch recht herzlich interessieren. Und mit denen wollen wir jetzt anfangen. Momentan ist es Platz 8, 41 Punkte, 11 Siege, 8 Unentschieden, 7 Niederlagen. Man ist punktgleich mit dem FCN, der ja das Derby, das haben wir noch gar nicht gesagt, aber das Derby führt sehr eindrucksvoll, gewonnen hat da noch ein letzter Satz zur Lage der Liga quasi. Aber zurück zu Düsseldorf, Trainer ist weiterhin Daniel Thun. Am Wochenende gab es ein 1-0-Sieg gegen Regensburg, ich glaube, es war der erste Sieg nach drei Spielen ohne Sieg. Vorher Niederlagen unter anderem gegen Hamburg und führt, Unentschieden im Derby gegen Köln. Einmal ganz kurz der Blick auf dieses Spiel gegen Regensburg, Jan. Was war denn dein Eindruck von dem Spiel?
Ich fange mal mit dem anderen Eindruck anderer an. Es gab danach auch einigen Unmut und Wut darüber, dass man dieses Spiel, wie man das Spiel gestaltet hat, quasi gegen die Regensburger, dann 1-0, dann am Ende knapp gewinnt. Es gibt in der letzten Minute dann noch die Chance für ein Regensburg zum Ausgleich. Es wäre aber der Lucky Punch gewesen. Also ich sehe das ein bisschen positiver, aber auch nur im Vergleich mit dem negativen Vorher, muss man sagen. Also die Lage der bei der Fortuna ist nicht so überzeugend sportlich, muss man leider feststellen. Gegen Regensburg hat man aber immerhin gesehen, dass Daniel Thunen einen Plan hatte, dass er umgestellt hat, mit zwei Spitzen. Vermeij hat mal wieder gespielt seit langem und nach meiner Auffassung hat er das auch wirklich sehr gut gemacht. 5-Torschuss-Vorlagen hat genau das geliefert, was er liefern sollte. Und wenn ich jetzt sage, dass es immerhin positiv ist, dann kann man erahnen, dass es in den letzten Wochen nicht immer so der Fall war, dass man da erkennen konnte, was der Trainer sich überlegt hatte. Und das hat die Fortuna zumindest gegen Regensburg diesen Plan auch umgesetzt. Man hätte das Spiel auch höher gewinnen können, müssen eigentlich– da sehe ich aber auch mit etwas stärkerer Milde drauf, weil Chancenverwertung ist eigentlich nicht das Problem der Fortuna in dieser Saison, sondern eher das der große Plus. Man hat wenig Chancen, aber die macht man dann in der Regel auch. Dann kann man sich so ein Spiel gegen Regensburg auch mal leisten. Hätte man dieses Spiel gegen andere Vertreter der 2. Liga gewonnen? Vielleicht nicht, weil die alten Schwächen, die man sieht in dieser Saison, die auch die Teilnahme an den Aufstiegskampf unwahrscheinlich macht, ist die defensiv Schwäche. Die hat man gegen Regensburg eben auch wieder gesehen. Jetzt tue ich den Regensburgern hoffentlich nicht unrecht, aber wenn man das gegen Regensburg sieht, dass die Fortuna da Schwächen hat, dann ist das kein gutes Zeichen für die Defensive der Fortuna. Ich bin zufrieden, wenn man unentschieden gespielt hätte, wenn man verloren hätte, hätte es auch eine unglaublich ungünstige Dynamik entwickeln können. Es raunt schon einiges Richtung Trainer, würde ich sagen, Richtung Mannschaft. Es ist ein Grummen und Raunen noch nicht mehr. Aber wenn man das gegen Regensburg jetzt nicht gewonnen hätte, dann wäre das sicherlich schwierig gewesen, da im Rest der Saison noch den Deckel drauf zu halten. Ich glaube immer noch, dass es Potenziale gibt, schwierig zu werden. Die Diskussion ist einfach nicht vorbei. Dafür war es in den letzten Wochen nicht überzeugend genug. Aber immerhin, vielleicht kann man sie ein bisschen versachlichen. Das hilft manchmal, habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Ja, ich finde halt, weil du gerade gesagt hast, mit Torverhältnis bzw. dass man es auch höher gewinnen könnte. Ich habe es mir mal angekündigt. Ich glaube, die Fortuna hat in den Top 9 tatsächlich das in Anführungszeichen schlechteste Torverhältnis. Also man hat ein Positives mit plus fünf. Aber es ist natürlich in einer Liga, die so eng ist, kann das gerade, sage ich jetzt mal vielleicht hinten raus, im Kampf um Platz drei gar nicht mehr so uninteressant werden. Wer hat da das beste Torverhältnis? Und dann sind eben andere Vereine ein bisschen besser auf. Aber wie du eben auch schon sagst, das liegt jetzt irgendwie nicht daran, dass man irgendwie ja seinen Chancen irgendwie hinterherhängt. Also laut WhoScore ist man da in beiden Bereichen. Also sowohl die Expected Goals für die geschossenen Tore sind ja nah dran. Also es ist halt eine Abweichung von minus 2,21. Also man hat fast ein bisschen mehr als zwei Tore weniger geschossen als ausgerechnet andersrum. Also es hängt immer so ein Spieltag hinterher, muss man dazu sagen. Oder es funktioniert immer nicht ganz rein. Da werden, glaube ich, auch die Standards immer raus, beziehungsweise die Elfmetertore, rausgerechnet. Und andersrum hätte man aber fast vier Gegentore mehr bekommen können, in der Theorie. Das ist dann natürlich immer so eine Rechnerei. Wie sieht es aus? Aber da, wie du schon sagst, das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so. Gerade Chancenverwertung ist man da schon relativ nahe dran. Du hast gerade gesagt, dass es ist schon ein bisschen Unruhe dabei, vor allem wenn man das vielleicht verloren hätte oder nur unentschieden. Man muss ja generell sagen, also wir reden bei Fortuna Düsseldorf immer ganz, oder bitte nicht bei Fortuna Düsseldorf, bei der 2. Liga reden wir immer ganz oft davon, dass es halt unfassbar wichtig ist, dass du irgendwie konstant in die Leistung bringst, dass du eben halt auch Serien aufbaust. Und da muss man ja einfach sagen, das hatte die Fortuna am Anfang mal wirklich, dass man da glaube ich 3 Spiele in Folge gewonnen hat, aber das war halt also wirklich Spieltag 3 bis 5, glaube ich. Und dann gab es eben so 2 ungeschlagen Serien, die sich so ein bisschen länger gezogen haben. Also vom 1. bis zum 7. Spieltag, jetzt mal nur in der Liga, DFB-Bukal mal ausgerechnet, und dann noch mal 14 bis 23. Aber jetzt zuletzt ist es ja schon so, dass man es nicht schafft, mal 2 Spiele in Folge zu gewinnen. Siehst du das auch so als Grundlage, dass die Stimmung da langsam so ein bisschen kippt?
Ich glaube, und da schließe ich mich eigentlich auch an, mit dieser Unruhe und dem Unbehagen, dass man gegenüber der sportlichen Leistung hat, dass man, wie du sagst, eigentlich am Anfang der Rückrunde und gegen Ende der Hinrunde eine Serie, zumindest das nicht verlierend, hingelegt hat. Aber man muss halt einfach konzentrieren, die Fortuna hat in dieser Phase vollkommen überperformt. Auch das mag man in der Tor-Differenz sehen. Also man hatte schon in der einen oder anderen Moment ein bisschen Glück. So Spiele, die man eventuell verliert oder unentschieden spielt, hat man eben nicht verloren. Der 1. FC Köln kann da auch von einem Lied singen, weil die hat es zweimal erwischt, die hätten zweimal gegen uns gewinnen müssen. Sie wissen wahrscheinlich bis heute nicht, wie sie das nicht geschafft haben. Aber das sind so Beispiele. Und ich glaube, dieses Gefühl, dass man eben überperformt hat, das zieht sich so ein bisschen durch. Das prägt eben das Bild auch. Wenn man diese beiden Serien vergleicht, dann hätte ich gedacht, am Ende dieser ersten Serie, also am Anfang der Saison, wurde ich gefragt, ob ich glaube, dass die Fortuna am Anfang mitspielen wird oder sogar aufsteigen wird. Und ich war mir eigentlich zu dem Zeitpunkt sicher, dass das der Fall sein würde, weil ich glaubte, dass die Fortuna einfach defensiv stabil sein würde. Entweder im besten Fall in einem Offensivsystem sich entwickelt, was noch funktioniert, oder aber mit der hohen individuellen Qualität, die man im Kader hat, auch offensiv irgendwie die Tore macht, die man braucht, um das ein oder andere Spiel zu gewinnen. Aber der Ausgangspunkt für meine Einschätzung, dass es eben gut laufen könnte in der Saison, ist eben die Defensive gewesen. Ich hätte es kaum ausgesprochen und seitdem hat sich etwas fundamental verändert. Diese defensive Stabilität hat die Fortuna vollkommen verloren. Es gibt sie nicht mehr. Es ist sehr instabil. Es hat verschiedene Gründe. Es hat einerseits mit der Kaderzusammensetzung zu tun, durchaus auch vielleicht mit Verletzungen. Mit dem großen, großen Problem, dass Daniel Thun immer noch am 25. Spieltag nicht das System gefunden hat, mit dem er eigentlich die Fortuna weiterentwickeln will und das Beste aus ihr sportlich rausholen will. Das hilft nicht, wenn die Vierer-Fünfer-Kette nicht eingespielt ist und das im Zusammenspiel mit den anderen Mannschaftszeilen, mit einem nicht ganz ideal aufgestellten defensiven Mittelfeld, mit einem nicht gut aufgestellten Außenverteidigern. Und dann kommen eben auch individuelle Schwächen hinzu. Jamil Zibert, der aus einer langen Verletzung zurückkam, hat es nicht geschafft, an die Leistungsfähigkeit heranzukommen, die er davor gezeigt hat. Was bei einem jungen Spieler vollkommen in Ordnung ist. Man sieht aber, dass es an ihm nagt, dass er damit harat, und dass es der Fortuna einfach wirklich nicht hilft. Der Letzte, den man für die Gegentore verantwortlich machen kann, in der Regel ist Florian Kastenmaier, der sicherlich auch dazu beiträgt, dass man zumindest auf dem Papier noch oben dran ist. Ein wirklich hervorragender Torhüter und Schlussmann, der sich auch immer in den letzten Jahren gesteigert hat. Man kann ihn gar nicht oft genug loben. Aber defensiv instabil, kein gutes Spielsystem nach vorne, und es muss halt irgendwie individuell gelöst werden, wie man Tore macht. Da kann ja sich jeder zusammenrechnen, dass das eigentlich nicht etwas ist, was eine Aufstiegsmannschaft ausmacht. Deswegen habe ich sie eben auch, als ich über Aufstiegskandidaten gesprochen habe, wohl weislich auch rausgelassen.
Ja, ich finde es halt so interessant, weil ich nämlich auch bei Düsseldorf immer das Gefühl habe, ich habe sie live gesehen im Stadion beim 1-0-Heimsieg gegen Hannover damals, was ich eigentlich tatsächlich kein schlechtes Spiel fand. Aber bei Hannover gab es seitdem auch noch mal einen Trainerwechsel. Aber für mich gibt es bei beiden Mannschaften halt schon relativ viele Parallelen, über die man irgendwie sprechen kann. Also dass da irgendwie der letzte Kern an Weiterentwicklung doch irgendwie fehlt und dass eben ausschlaggebend dafür sein kann und vor allem halt in der Saison fehlt. Also es ist ja das eine, wenn du es irgendwie nicht schaffst über den Sommer. Und da muss man ja einfach sagen, was bei Düsseldorf einfach tragisch. Wir brauchen jetzt nicht zum 800. Mal diese Relegation aufarbeiten, aber das ist natürlich immer schwieriger und man muss da natürlich sagen, dass man da überweitest oder ja ein Großteil des Kaders einfach zusammenhalten konnte, was natürlich auch nicht selbstverständlich ist oder auf jeden Fall so, also für mich als Außenstehende ganz, ganz viele, jetzt mal ausgenommen von einem Jollist oder so, aber einfach solche Spieler halten konnte, auch einen Kastenmayer etc., also dass dieses Fundament steht, aber dass eben jetzt halt schon so ist, du guckst dir drei Spiele von Fortuna an und es stehen immer, also es ist eine andere Formation, es sind andere Spieler und du weißt irgendwie nicht so ganz, okay, was ist denn jetzt die Spielidee hier? Und das ist natürlich, wenn mir da schon als Außenstehender auffällt, ist das ein Problem. Als Fan kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es sehr frustrierend ist.
Ja, also man kann Daniel Thun ja auch dabei auf der Suche zuschauen, wie du sagst und man kann ihn auch beim Verzweifeln zusehen. Also wer nach dem 1 zu 4 in Hamburg länger drangeblieben ist, sah Daniel Thun im Kreis der Spieler stehen und bei jedem zweiten Wort, das er gesagt hat, und es ist keine Übertreibung, hat er mit der Züchter geschuckt. Und es war halt ein Bild, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht mehr weiter, kurz davor saß er neben der Auswechselbank, der Trainerbank, in dem Dunkeln gekauert und das Bild des hadernden, kauernden Tun, was man auch aus diesem Relikationsspiel in Hamburg zu Hause kannte, das verfolgt ihn auch so ein bisschen. Also das Gefühl hat, manchmal ist er zu passiv, greift während des Spiels dann zu wenig ein oder irgendwie versucht, das Ruder zu wenig rumzureißen. Und in den letzten Wochen hat er auch auf den Pressekonferenzen genauso gewirkt, wie er in diesem Kreis der Spieler gegen Hamburg stand und hat mehr oder weniger gesagt, ja, die Spieler machen eben nicht das, was wir abgesprochen haben, ich erreiche die Mannschaft nicht mehr. Und wenn das ein Trainer sagt, dann ist das ein großes Warnsignal. Und es liegt nicht allein an ihm. Es ist, glaube ich, diese Saison kommt etwas dazu, was in den letzten Saisons anders gelaufen ist. Ich glaube, der Kader, den er zur Verfügung hat, ist nicht der Kader, der Daniel-Tune-Fußball, zumindest bei der Fortuna in den letzten Jahren, ausgemacht hat. Das war sehr stark von einem sehr dominant wichtigen Rechtsverteidiger, Matthias Zimmermann, geprägt. Das Spiel, der, egal welches Spiel man sah, er hatte immer die meisten Ballkontakte, der ist jetzt ins offensiveste Mittelfeld geschoben worden zum Teil, weil man da eben eine große Lücke hat, weil da Spieler fehlen. Da überzeugt er aber weniger. Jetzt gegen Regensburg war es was anderes. Dann saß er lange auf der Bank. Dann spielt Lundahl aber eine vollkommen andere Position. Und was für Daniel Thun bei der Fortuna immer wichtig war, waren eben auch die offensiven Außen. Solis, Narei mag man sich noch daran erinnern. Und da gibt es bei der Fortuna aktuell niemanden, der das spielen kann. Es gibt schon Spieler, die diese Theorie spielen können. Van Brederode wurde geholt, in der Hoffnung wahrscheinlich, dass er das können müsste. Bisher hat er das noch nicht so auf dem Niveau konstant gezeigt, auch wenn er immer wieder hat aufblitzen lassen, was er kann. Auf rechts außen hat man, glaube ich, gehofft, dass Felix Klaus irgendwie noch eine stabile Saison hinkriegt. Und Tim Rossmann kam lange verletzt aus Karlsruhe und ist jetzt auch wieder angeschlagen. Also es fehlt eben für Daniel Thun die Eckpunkte seines Fußballs. Und ihm gelingt halt im laufenden Betrieb nicht, das irgendwie auszugleichen. Und das ist etwas, was natürlich auch den Unmut und auch seine Person sehr stark in den Blick rückt, auch wenn man eben die gesamte sportliche Führung und Leitung mit Klaus Allaus und Christian Weber auch mit reinrechnen muss.
Ja, also es gab halt eben ein paar Wintertransfers, also beziehungsweise zwei Zugänge mit Moritz Heier vom HSV, eine Vestiverpflichtung und dann Moritz Brünning-Quarteng, kennt man glaube ich aus der 2. Liga vor allem von Magdeburg, hat es dann zu Bochum gewechselt, wo er dann jetzt weniger eine Rolle gespielt hat, glaube ich. Und eben dann Felix Klaus beispielsweise zu Führer, Jordi De Weis zu Herren Wehen und Sima Zuzo zu Hansa Rostock, also vor allem Letzterer per Laie. Also heißt auch, verstärkungstechnisch, zwei Spieler, die man eben außer 2. Liga kennt. Wie willst du denn deren Einfluss auf die aktuelle Fortuna beschreiben?
Ja, Moritz Haya hat eine sehr deuntagbare Rolle zugekommen, weil er in einer nicht unbedingt gut funktionierenden Mannschaft hineingeworfen wurde und dann auch noch eine Position links Verteidiger spielen musste, die nicht seine Stärken aufzeigt, würde ich mal sagen. Ich glaube, man hat ihn einfach geholt, um einen Stabilitätsfaktor zu haben. Einen, der halt die 2. Liga kennt, der mehrere Positionen spielen kann. Und hier auch eben einen sauberen Job macht. Man hat nicht erwartet, dass er jetzt irgendwie offensiv Input gibt und so weiter und so fort. Das ist ihm als Links Verteidiger nicht immer gelungen. Aber jetzt zum Beispiel gegen Regensburg hat er halt in der 3. Kette den linken Innenverteidiger gegeben. Das war sehr bestimmt besser und ich glaube, das kommt aus seinen Stärken mehr entgegen. Ich fand den Transfer gut, weil er etabliert ist, verfügbar in der Wintertransferperiode und weil er mehrere Positionen spielen kann, was in einem lückenhaften Kader immer vorteilhaft ist. Es ist ein klassischer Transfer. Man muss vielleicht die Fehler der Sommers wieder gut machen. Bei Quateng kann man zwei Dinge sagen. Einmal kann man über die Kaderplanung sprechen und einmal darüber, wie gescoutet wird. Im letzten Winter kam Quateng aus Bochum. Im letzten Winter kam daferner aus Nürnberg. Rat mal, was Bochum und Nürnberg gemeinsam hatten. Oder wen die gemeinsam hatten. Richtig, Dieter Hecking. Natürlich kennt Klaus Alauf Dieter Hecking noch aus Wolfsburg. Da wird natürlich auch kurz angerufen, hast du noch einen? Ja, habe ich noch. Dann ist der Transfer eingetütet. Ob das immer spielerisch passt, weiß man nicht. Bisher hat es bei beiden letztes Jahr nicht funktioniert. Bei Quateng hat es am Anfang so ausgesehen, als ob er ein Faktor sein könnte. Das erste Spiel war super. Danach ist er auch in diesen dysfunktionalen Strudel mit reingekommen und ist jetzt auch verletzt und fällt den Rest der Saison aus. Dafür kann niemand was, aber es hilft natürlich nicht. Er wird der Fortuna-Offensiv nicht mehr helfen können. Ob er das in der Rolle, die er in den letzten Spielen hatte, überhaupt hätte tun können, ist eine andere Frage.
Aber würdest du schon so weit gehen, dass– also ich meine, es sind ja jetzt auf den Relegationsplatz nur vier Punkte. Die kann man ja schnell auffüllen, grundsätzlich. Aber würdest du vielleicht sogar sagen, es wäre gar nicht so verkehrt, jetzt schon auf die nächste Saison zu schauen, diese Saison schon mal so ein bisschen an den Kleiderbügel zu hängen und vielleicht noch so ein bisschen zu betrachten, schauen, was geht, aber sich vor allem darauf zu konzentrieren, wie sieht der Kader aus in der nächsten Saison? Wollen wir nächstes Jahr wirklich mit Daniel Tune noch als Trainer in die Saison gehen, was natürlich, muss ich sagen, eigentlich ein fatales Zeichen ist, wenn du mit ihm vor einigen Wochen, Monaten erst verlängerst. Groß prosauns, du stehst hinter dem Trainer, ihm eigentlich auch keinen Druck machst, dass er aufsteigen muss, den dann vor die Tür setzen würdest, aber grundsätzlich stimme ich dir zu. Ich meine, ich wohne in Düsseldorf und war in dieser Saison auch schon einige Male bei der Fortuna in Stockholm, in der Arena und habe mir das angeschaut und kann das alles, was hier gesagt wurde, teilen. Man kriegt gefühlt jeden Spieltag eine andere Fortuna zu sehen und auch dieses Bild des verzweifelten Tunes hat sich bei mir eingebrannt. Da ist wenig, wie man heutzutage sagt, Aura übrig geblieben am Spielfeldrand, die vielleicht die Spieler auch nochmal pusht. Die Mütze, vor allem in den Wintermonaten, rutscht immer tiefer ins Gesicht. Vielleicht würde es sogar dem Verein guttun, aber irgendwie würde es mir auch da wieder leidtun. Auch das größere Bild, die Entwicklung des Fußballs, weil du halt gar keine Entwicklung mehr zulässt. Jetzt ist es ja auch nicht so, dass Tune schon seit 15 Jahren, da ist ich weiß gar nicht, drei, vier Jahre, drei Jahre. Also da ist ja eigentlich, er hat schon was angestoßen und ist jetzt vielleicht in einer Krise. Und das ist eigentlich schon das richtige Zeichen vom Verein, zu sagen, wir tragen dich auch durch diesen Bump in der gemeinsamen Beziehung und wir setzen uns im Sommer hin, schauen, dass wir wieder zusammenfinden. Aber ja, würde mich mal interessieren, wohin du da tendierst, als jemand, der dem Verein ja sehr nahe verbunden ist.
Ja, ich glaube, dass die Trainerfrage ist ganz wichtig und deine Ausgangsbemerkungen sind Treffen ein ganz, ganz entscheidender Punkt. Ich glaube, die nächsten Wochen und Monate werden ganz wichtig für die Fortuna sein. Und ich würde genau dafür plädieren, klar muss man immer noch de facto zweigleisig planen, aber eigentlich sollte man schauen, dass man für die 2. Liga plant, dass man überlegt, wie viel Geld hat man zur Verfügung, was muss man machen, wen wird man wahrscheinlich abgeben, aus finanziellen Gründen, Johannes Hahn und so weiter und so fort. Was sind die Kaderplätze, wo wir jetzt schon potenzielle 2. Liga-Spieler ansprechen können, mit denen in Kontakt kommen können, ist zwar nicht immer erlaubt, aber das kann man ja trotzdem machen und eine Kaderplanung nach vorne treiben. Es werden im Sommer diverse Spieler den Verein verlassen, verlassen müssen. Es laufen Verträge, Träger aus. Es werden Spieler abgegeben werden müssen, aus finanziellen Gründen. Da hat man jetzt, wie du es auch sagst, hätte man ja den Vorteil, dass man eben, wenn man jetzt in die Planung geht für die 2. Liga, wenn man sich jetzt entscheidet für Daniel Thun, wenn man einen anderen Trainer haben will, wird es schwieriger. Aber dann könnte man ja sagen, woran lag es, was waren die Kaderlücken und was können wir noch machen. Und da kneift sich so ein bisschen mein Eindruck davon, wie Daniel, wie Klaus Alofs Kaderplanung betreibt. Klaus Alof setzt stark und wie ich finde, zu stark auf die Dynamiken des sich schließenden Transferfensters, wo halt Spieler, die eventuell gehofft haben, wo sich auch zu verbessern oder die im Trainingslager gemerkt haben, dass sie nicht mehr so zur Verfügung stehen, dass sie eben nicht in dem Verein, wo sie gerade sind, eine Zukunft haben werden, wo sie sich nochmal umgucken, wo die Spielerberater aktiv werden. Und das ist das Berater-Scouting, das glaube ich, ist eine Unterstellung von mir, aber ich glaube, da gibt es sehr starke Indizien dafür, dass Alof sehr stark betreibt. Das kann gut gehen, wie man im Fall Zolles sehen kann, wie man bei Meijo Hanesson sehen kann, den hat man auf gar keinen Fall bei FC Kopenhagen gescoutet, sondern das läuft über Berater. Was aber jetzt in dieser Phase wichtig wäre, wäre eine langfristige Planung mit 2. Liga, mit guten 3. Liga-Spielern. Das gab es auch immer wieder. Das gibt es auch mit Janek Engelhardt in der vorletzten Saison, zum Beispiel Tim Rossmann, den man eben von Karlsruhe geholt hat, der in der Verletzung da fest saß. Aber ich glaube, das müsste man jetzt noch stärker machen, auch aus finanziellen Gründen, weil auch die Spieler, die dann aus England kommen, weil sie da irgendwie im riesigen Kader keinen Platz mehr kriegen oder aus Champions-League-Teilnehmenden, dänischen Vereinen, die verdienen natürlich trotzdem ordentlich Geld, mehr Geld als ein guter Drittligaspieler oder halt ein guter Zweitligaspieler. Du hast vollkommen recht, das ist eine ganz, ganz wichtige Phase und man sollte jetzt eigentlich– ich wüsste jetzt gerne, ich würde den Mäuschen-Joker jetzt gerne ziehen und gucken, was passiert.
Ja, und was natürlich da super spannend für diesbezüglich ist ja wirklich, also diese Entwicklungsfrage, die gestellt werden muss, weil also eine Sache, über die wir jetzt noch nicht gesprochen haben, aber die ja auch zu diesem nährt, warum man eben vier Plätze hinter dem Relegationsplatz ist, dass man ja die Top-Spiele, also Top-Spiele habe ich jetzt persönlich mal die Partien bezeichnet, gegen alle, die über einem stehen, also gegen die Top-7. Da hat man jetzt, wenn ich richtig nachgezählt habe, in zehn Spielen nur acht Punkte geholt. So, das ist enorm ein einzigen Sieg gegen Hannover am vierten Spieltag. Also, das Spiel habe ich gesehen.
Du hast sie gesehen.
Vielleicht muss ich häufiger zu Top-Spielen gehen.
Gerne.
Sonst unentschieden oder eben niederlagen. Und das ist natürlich, also das hat dann jemand, der teilweise im Forum dann auch nochmal festgehalten, dass das eben nicht nur eine Erkenntnis dieser Saison ist, sondern immer, also in den letzten drei Saisons seit Hyundai ist, immer wieder auftaucht. Und da muss man ja einfach sagen, also letztes Jahr hat es dann ja trotzdem für die Relegation gereicht, aber man muss ja trotzdem sagen, ist ja schön, dass du irgendwie die Spiele gegen den Rest irgendwie gewinnst oder zumindest unentschieden spielst, aber diese ganz, ganz vielen Unentschieden gegen die Top-Teams da mit drin, das reicht halt nicht, wenn du dich da oben festsetzen willst.
Also das ist sicherlich auch ein Kritikpunkt an Tune, den man festmachen kann. Ich glaube der Post bei mitmachen.rasenfunk.de sagte ja auch, dass Tune seine Identität aufgeben würde in solchen Spielen und für die letzte Saison kann man das auf jeden Fall festmachen. Bei dieser Saison könnte man ja ein bisschen polemisch sagen, naja, er gibt ja keine Identität auf, weil er hat noch keine gefunden. Ja, also gibt es diese Tendenz trotzdem. Ja, trotzdem stimmt es natürlich, dass da halt irgendwie versucht wird, Beton anzurühren oder sich zumindest hinten reinzustellen, Defensive erstmal die Null zu halten. Gegen HSV macht man das sehr gerne. Und es klappt dabei in der Regel nicht. Ja, weil man eben Sachen aufgibt wie letzte Saison. Und in dieser Saison werden halt von den besseren Teams, von den guten Teams auch die Defizite im Verbund komplett aufgelegt, offen gelegt. Und dann kriegt man halt gegen einen sehr starken HSV einfach vier Dinge, hätte auch noch mehr kassieren können. Und auch gegen andere Mannschaften hat man dann eben keine Chance.
Ja, ich bin mal tatsächlich gespannt. Also weil so die nächsten Spiele sind dann ja unter anderem gegen Kaiserslautern, dann Auswitz in Münster und dann zu Hause gegen Paderborn. Also du und ich glaube, du spielst dann ja auch zum Ende noch gegen Magdeburg und so. Also es kommen ja und Nürnberg ist glaube ich auch noch dabei und so. Also diese ganzen, also die stand jetzt über allem stehen. Da kommen ja noch relativ viele Partien vergleichsweise. Und wenn du halt bis zum Ende mitdrehen willst, also brauche ich nicht lange rechnen, wenn du die Teams überholen willst, musst du gegen sie erstmal gewinnen. Also das ist eine relativ einfache Rechnung, um eben diese Teams hinter sich zu lassen. Und das ist es halt eben, noch hast du ja alles in der eigenen Hand. Aber da bin ich auch tatsächlich sehr, sehr gespannt, wie sich das alles entwickelt. Weil, also ich finde den Einwurf von Dominik super wichtig. Also es gibt dann natürlich diese, du kannst ja eigentlich nicht vor vier Wochen irgendwie oder vor ein paar Wochen mit dem Trainer verlängern oder langfristig verlängern und ihn dann im Sommer rausschmeißen. Und dann machst du dir wieder eine neue Finanzstelle auf. Auf der anderen Seite, wie sieht das aus, wie kriegst du das auch nach außen hin verkauft und so. Das spielt da ja alles mit rein.
Genau. Und deshalb ist es auch wichtig, dass man diese Saison gut abschließt. Also jetzt mit dem Aufstieg damit rechne ich einfach nicht mehr. Aber eben damit man eine Planung hat mit dem Trainer. Und das also auch ich finde die Fragen und auch die kritischen Fragen an Daniel Thun sehr berechtigt. Also ich kann da jedenfalls muss vielleicht nicht pfeifen und ihn irgendwie zum Teufel wünschen. Aber einen kritischen Blick kann man auch haben. Und man kann auch mit guten Argumenten sagen, gibt vielleicht auch mehr Gegenargumente gegen ihn. Das ist bei mir noch nicht so. Aber umso wichtiger wäre es jetzt, dass man irgendwie die Spiele gut über den rüber bringt und eben eine Entwicklung sieht. Und sei es, dass man einfach eine defensive Stabilität hinbekommt. Das ist dann nicht schön anzuschauen, aber es ist schon zumindest ein wichtiger Ausgangspunkt, um erfolgreich in den Zweitliga-Fußball zu spielen. Also zumindest mit Daniel Thun. Es mag Trainer geben, die das anders können, aber bei Thun glaube ich nicht.
Eine letzte Sache noch, bevor wir dann noch gleich weiter gehen zu Schalke, weil das auch ihm im Forum gewünscht wurde. Und zwar geht es um das Projekt Fortuna für alle, das ja seine zweite Saison macht. Auch hier waren vier Spiele vorgesehen. Drei davon haben schon stattgefunden. Alle hat man nicht gewonnen. Gegen Hamburg, gegen Elversberg und gegen Darmstadt. Gegen Preuß Münster ist das nächste und auch das letzte. Das ist das erste Heimspiel nach der Länderspielpause. Generell ein paar Zahlen, weil es da vor Kurzem darum ging. Also per se zum Image-Transfer, kann man ja so sagen. Das spielt natürlich immer eine große Woche. Es wurde, glaube ich, gesagt, dass 70% aller TeilnehmerInnen einer Fan-Umfrage zum Abschluss der letzten Saison gesagt haben, dass das ihr Bild auf den Verein oder das Projekt an sich, das sehr positiv bewerten, dass sich die Identifikation mit dem Verein verbessert habe. Das hat jeder Zweite gesagt. Generell, dass der Verein deutschlandweit anders wahrgenommen wird und eben auch die, ich sage mal, zuständigen Sponsors, gerade Tago Bank oder so, schon durchaus da auch ihre Nutzen rausgezogen haben. Es gibt natürlich auch enorme Kritik, gerade außer Fanszene, weil dann natürlich immer die Diskussion aufgeht, ja, ist es zu viel Eventpublikum, etc. Wie blickst du denn aus Fan-Perspektive, aber eben auch aus Experten-Perspektive auf dieses Projekt?
Ich glaube, das muss, also genau, man kann es halt trennen. Einmal die Fan-Perspektive, die soziale Komponente, was macht es mit dem Stadion und dann eben, was macht es irgendwie auch langfristig mit dem Verein. Zum ersten, also man kann einfach nicht von der Hand weisen, was für einen absoluten wichtigen Faktor es für Menschen mal ausmacht, wenn es einfach keinen Eintritt kostet. Es wurden ja auch gezielt Karten abgegeben an Menschen, die sich das normalerweise nicht leisten können. Alle anderen haben sich auch beworben darüber, hatten dahin zumindest Chancen. Das ist ein wichtiger Faktor und das will ich nicht kleinreden. Das ist auch, glaube ich, das Argument, was mich am meisten überzeugt. Klar wird das auch vom Verein sehr stark nach außen getragen, CSR und so weiter und so fort, aber das ist halt einfach etwas, was ich nicht von der Hand weisen möchte. Die Spiele selber waren, glaube ich, von der Erfahrung sehr gemischt und auch zum Teil recht negativ für diejenigen, die einfach immer hingehen. Weil die Dynamiken in diesem Stadion zwar voll ist, aber wo halt ein Großteil der Menschen vielleicht nicht regelmäßig hingehen oder halt wo auch Zusammenhänge, die es normalerweise auch beim 25.000, 30.000 besetzten Stadion eben gibt, aufgelöst worden waren. Das heißt, man hat ein volles Haus, aber die Stimmung war meistens schlechter, als wenn 30.000 da sind. Das ist vielleicht einfach ein Nebeneffekt und dem muss man Zeit geben. Es geht ja auch darum, neue Leute anzusprechen, für die Fortuna zu interessieren und eben in der zweitgrößten Schattung Nordrhein-Westfalen eben die Leute nicht zu den Randvereinen gehen, die zwar in Düsseldorf wohnen, aber nicht dort Fans sind, dass man die dafür sich gewinnt. Das ist ja ein langfristiger Wachstumsprozess und das muss man, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen hinnehmen. Es macht trotzdem was mit einem, wenn man denkt, Leute, wir sind auf 50.000 und irgendwie gibt es hier keinen Zug drin, obwohl die Saison war es nicht so gut, aber letzte Saison liefen die Spiele ja durchaus stark. Einfach so, dass sich das nicht widerspiegelt. Das fühlt sich nicht so an, als ob 50.000 da sind. Das macht Frust. Die andere Seite ist, Fortuna für alle ist eine Marketingstrategie. Man will eben die Einnahmen, die man durch den Ticketverkauf verliert, durch mehr Marketingeinnahmen, nur mehr Sponsoreneinnahmen wieder reinholen und sogar noch mehr damit machen. Unabhängiger werden von den doch etwas manchmal launischen Fortuna-Fans, wenn es um Zahlen von Tickets geht. Da wird sich jetzt zeigen mit dem nächsten Finanzbericht, der jetzt für das laufende Jahr rauskommt, ob das irgendwie annäherungsweise aufgeht. Weil jetzt ist ein relativ großer Sponsor noch eingestiegen. Das war lange eher dümpelt, ist sich vor sich hin. Und bisher hat man es noch nicht gesehen im aktuellen Bericht für die letzten Jahre. Und das ist natürlich ein Spannungsfeld, das der Verein mit sich rumträgt. Ja, verzichtet man auf die sicheren Einnahmen durch die Ticketverkäufe, die man einfach hat, weil man relativ für die 2. Liga hohes Level an Zuschauern eben hat. Und das ist ein Risiko, das man eingeht. Ein finanzielles Risiko und finanzielle Risiken sind bei der Fortuna mit gewissen Vorgeschichten behaftet, mit gewissen Schuldenständen, die man hat und mit ein bisschen schlechten finanziellen Situationen. Und ich glaube darin ist auch das größte Risiko bei Fortuna für alle. Ich weiß, ich mache jetzt ein bisschen groß das Thema auf, aber Alexander Jobst, der Dominik ja vielleicht noch aus seinen Schalker-Zeiten kennt, Alexander Jobst, das ist sein Projekt. Das ist Alexander Jobst Projekt, das für seine Karriere entscheidend ist. Alexander Jobst hat einen großen, ich glaube einen großen Ehrgeiz. Und ich weiß nicht, ob die Fortuna für ihn die letzte Station ist. Für ihn ist es wichtig, dass Fortuna für alle erfolgreich ist. Und für den Aufsichtsrat, der Jobst eingestellt hat und der jetzt bei jeden Dokumentationen über Fortuna für alle gerne sein Gesicht dahin hält, ist es auch wichtig, dass das so wichtig ist. Die sind eng miteinander verbunden. Nun kann man sich eine Situation vorstellen, dass das eben nicht klappt, dass die Marketeileinnahmen nicht so steigen, wie die Einnahmen für Ticketverkäufe sinken und dass damit ein finanzielles Risiko für die Fortuna entsteht. Und Jobst hat einfach mal gesagt, ja, dann wenn es nicht klappt, dann steigen wir wieder um und dann verkaufen wir Tickets. Aber so einfach ist es natürlich nicht. Was ist mit dieser Phase, wo es eben kippt, wo die Entscheidung getroffen werden muss, bleiben wir jetzt einfach noch eine Saison dabei und müssen ja noch mehr Spiele, das ist ja auch besprochen mit den Sponsoren, freigeben und eben noch weniger Einnahmen über Ticketverkäufe generieren, nehmen wir dieses Risiko ein. Und die Situation in der Vereinsführung ist, dass es wenige Stimmen vielleicht gibt, die ein Interesse daran haben, dass dieses Projekt eben dann, dass man eingestehen muss, dass es gescheitert ist. Es gibt eben sehr viele Potente, für die es sehr sehr wichtig ist, dass es funktioniert. Das ist eben das Risiko, dass die Fortuna mit sich herumträgt und dass man auch nicht klein reden sollte. Vielleicht ist es auch nicht so groß, wie ich es jetzt irgendwie aufgemacht habe, aber das ist etwas, was mich auf jeden Fall auch herumtreibt, weil die Fortuna hat eine lange Geschichte an schwierigen finanziellen Situationen. Vielleicht kommen wir gleich beim nächsten Verein auch dazu. Aber das könnte sich eben auch erweisen, dass das eben auch ein Risiko ist, dass man das nach hinten losgeht.
Ja, ich finde es tatsächlich super spannend und ich bin auch sehr gespannt, was da rauskommt. Man hat auch das Gefühl, wenn man einfach nur einmal Fortuna für alle googelt, also Sky Doku und hier OMR und da und dies, da wird auch ordentlich nochmal die, ich glaube einfach nach außen hin, auch durchaus die Marketing-Schiene angeschmissen, was halt, also wie du es erklärt hast, auch sehr verständlich ist. Aber ich glaube, ich bin mal tatsächlich gespannt, was eben nach dieser Saison und mit den Finanzkennzahlen, also wichtiger Hinweis, vielleicht reden wir dann nochmal darüber, wie es dann weitergeht, weil ich, also das ist dann ja fast auch schon wieder so ein Tribünengesprächthema, weil man da glaube ich sehr, sehr lange drüber reden kann, weil es einfach, also und auch einfach für dieses Format dann viel zu sehr in Kennzahlen geht, die, wo ich dann ehrlich gesagt auch jedenfalls raus will, da hört mein Verständnis auf. Aber das ist ja auch einfach ein guter, ich würde sagen, das ist eine gute Überleitung in ganz Kennzahlen zu unserem nächsten Verein. Jan hat mir meine Überleitung schon weggenommen. Wir wollen natürlich über den FC Schalke 04 auch noch sprechen. Dominik hat jetzt lange durchgehalten. Der steht auf Platz 11. Er hat 33 Punkte, 9 Siege, 6 Unentschieden, 11 Niederlagen. Das Punkt gleich mit führt auf Platz 12. Man hat 10 Punkte Vorsprung auf Platz 16, was per se ja nach diesem Saisonverlauf vielleicht gar nicht, dass man so schlecht klingt. Der Trainer ist Kees van Wonderen seit dem 9. Spieltag. Und das ist kurz bevor du das heißt, als du mal hier warst, Dominik. Am Freitagabend gab es eine 1 zu 2 Niederlage gegen Hannover nach 1-0 Führung. Also wirklich eine sehr, sehr bittere Niederlage. Es war per se, ich glaube, man muss sagen, die vierte Niederlage in 2025. Und da waren vor allem eben drei selbst designierte Spitzen-Teams, würde ich mal sagen, dabei mit Magdeburg, Köln und Hannover. Der vierte war dann Darmstadt. Die Spiele gegen Hertha und Münster zum Beispiel hat man gewonnen. Dominik, reinsportlich gesehen erstmal, wie bewertest du da denn die Lage des FC Schalke?
Das, was ich Jan von gefragt habe, würde ich sagen, ist bei Schalke Realität. Also die Saison ist gelaufen, spätestens jetzt mit dem Spiel gegen Hannover. Ich glaube, vor dem Spiel gegen Hannover, deswegen ist man ja Schalker, und da zähle ich mich auch mit rein, um mein Umfeld, geht man in das Spiel gegen Hannover und denkt, wenn man jetzt gegen Hannover 3 Punkte holt, 36 Punkte und 8 führt und Ulm, da nehmen wir auch noch mal jeweils 3 Punkte mit und vielleicht geht da ja doch noch mal was, das ist ja eine enge Liga und so weiter und so fort. Und dann sieht man ab der 84. Minute, warum der FC Schalke 04 in der Saison 2024-25 eben im Mittelfeld rumdümpelt und gar nichts mit dem Aufstieg zu tun hat. Und dann geht man eben raus und sagt, jo, nehme ich die paar Heimspiele nur mit. Ist ja auch eigentlich immer ganz nett auf Schalke, aber irgendwie groß Sorgen machen oder zittern werden wir jetzt diese Saison nicht. Matthias Tillmann hat ja auch schon öfters gesagt, sein großes Ziel ist, dass man in dieser Saison so früh wie möglich 40 Punkte erreicht. Ich glaube, das ist ein ganz gutes Ziel in Kombination, damit, dass man vielleicht noch den einen oder anderen Tabellenplatz tatsächlich gut macht, wegen der TV-Gelder. Aber ja, es ist halt wieder so eine Transit-Saison, die einfach so irgendwann in den Büchern verschwinden wird. Man wird auch in diesem Sommer wieder einen großen Umbruch haben, auch wenn Juri Möller als Interimssportdirektor und wahrscheinlich ab Sommer dann Sportvorstand und Ben Manga als technischer Direktor bzw. Direktor Kaderplanung sich immer hinstellen und sagen, nein, unser Ziel ist es, das Team so gut wie möglich zusammenzuhalten und dann uns in der Spitze zu verstärken. Ich glaube, das ist reines Wunschdenken. Allein, wenn man schon sieht, dass man zwar mit Thailand Bulut verlängert hat, was die Schalker Fan-Gemeinde komplett angezündet hat, weil er auf jeden Fall der Senkrechtsstarter der Saison und mit Kapitän Kenan Karaman und Goalgetter Musa Sila sicherlich der beste Spieler der Saison war. Aber man hat mit ihm verlängert und ihm anscheinend eine so läppische Ablöse, Summe- bzw. Ausstiegsklausel reingeschrieben, dass er eigentlich jetzt schon aussuchen kann, für welchen Verein er jetzt im Sommer oder ab Sommer spielt. Und das wird wahrscheinlich, du hattest ja vorhin schon ein paar Memes genannt, das kann ich mir dann bei Schalke auch vorstellen, dass da dann der ein oder andere Dominostein mit umfällt. Und dann vielleicht der eine oder andere Spieler, wenn aktuelle Leistungsträger gehen, sich fragt, können wir diese Lücke erneut füllen, können wir diese Saison aber wirklich angreifen. Und ich sehe da auch für 2025, 2026 eine sehr harte Saison für Schalke voraus. Es gibt ja jetzt auch schon zunehmend Rumoren. Ich möchte jetzt nicht es als Gerücht direkt flaggen, aber man nimmt es auf jeden Fall wahr als Rumoren, ob es im Sommer auch überhaupt mit Ben Manga weitergeht, welche Ausrichtung Schalke ab Sommer haben wird. Ich hatte das letzte Mal, als ich im Rasenfunk war, die Verpflichtung von Ben Manga grundsätzlich kutiert und gesagt, da ist jemand, der eine klare Agenda mit sich bringt. Das ist eigentlich das, was Schalke braucht und das es auch jemand, der Erfahrung hat. Und wenn jemand wie er auf dem Markt ist und sich Schalke anbietet, dann muss man dazugreifen und gibt dem Mann seine Freiheiten. Jetzt einige Monate später muss man konstatieren, ja, man hat ihm die Freiheiten gegeben. Ja, er hat einigen Personen, unter anderem Karol Geraz, damit ordentlich auf den Schlips getreten und vermutlich, wenn nicht direkt, aber indirekt, den Job gekostet. Und man muss auch sagen, seine Transferbilanzstand heute ist eine, naja, ich möchte nicht sagen verheerende, aber eine überhaupt nicht positive, weil abgesehen von Sila, der aktuell verletzt ist, hat da eigentlich keiner seiner Transfers wirklich gezündet. Ich weiß, wir hatten das letzte Mal, als ich zu Gast war, über Philippe Sánchez gesprochen, den er aus Argentinien verpflichtet hat, den Gerats nicht so eingesetzt hat, wie es sich offenbar Manga gewünscht hat, auf den auch Kies van Wonderen nicht setzt. Kies van Wonderen hat jetzt erst vom Spiel gegen Hannover in einer Pressekonferenz gesagt, also knallhart eigentlich, Philippe Sánchez ist noch nicht so weit, er ist noch kein Zweitligaspieler und das ist schon ein dickes Stück für jemanden, für den man über eine Million Euro als deutscher Zweitligist hingelegt hat, dem dann einfach auch nach acht, neun Monaten da zu bilanzieren, du bist nicht auf unserem Niveau und da zieht dann halt auch nicht mehr dieses Argument von Manga aus dem Spätsommer, frühen Herbst, aber der Junge hat ja auch schon gegen Boca Juniors und River Plate Stamm gespielt. Das mag alles sein, aber wenn zwei Trainer sozusagen übereinstimmt, zu dem Ergebnis kommen, der Spieler ist aber halt noch nicht gut genug, um gegen Hannover Stamm zu spielen, dann kannst du dich auch nicht darauf ausruhen, dass du irgendwann mal im Bombonera gespielt hast. Also es ist mal wieder eine total unübersichtliche, frustrierende auch Gemengelage auf Schalke. Wenn man es optimistisch sehen möchte, kann man sagen, es bleibt spannend, es wird ein spannender Sommer. Ich bin ja auch jemand, der total empfänglich ist für allerlei Transfergerüchte und so weiter. Von daher werde ich da wahrscheinlich spannende Wochen und Monate verbringen, verschiedene Kanäle täglich updaten und schauen, was es da für ein neues Wunschdenken gibt. Wenn wir schon bei Wunschdenken sind, das kann ich auch direkt schon mal in diesem Monolog abhaken. Raoul zu Schalke als Trainer finde ich aktuell komplett Quatsch, wird im Sommer wahrscheinlich auch nicht passieren. Warum sollte sich Raoul das antun? Außer jetzt natürlich wieder das Wort Aura, was soll er mitbringen, was er in Kies van Wonderen jetzt aktuell nicht hat. Weil Raoul war bei Real Castilla, viele Jahre Trainer, hat er jetzt aber auch nicht irgendwie krass aufmerksam gemacht. Ich habe auch des Öfteren von Leuten gehört, dass er auch keinen per se attraktiven Fußball spielen lässt, sondern eher defensiv orientierten Fußball, wo auch es wieder heißt, dass man eigentlich jetzt seit den letzten 5 Jahren oder den letzten 5 Trainern immer sagt, man möchte weg davon, dass es so defensiv orientiert ist, man will mehr aktiven Fußball. Und so sehr ich Raoul Liebe als Schalker-Legende, wenn er schon aus Spanien heraus den Hof hat, eher ein defensiv agierender Trainer zu sein, auch wenn er selbst ein begnadeter Offensivspieler ist, dann weiß ich nicht, warum man auf Krampf diese Legenden-Nummer irgendwie, sozusagen, erzwingen möchte, wenn alle anderen, sag ich mal, rationalen, sportlichen Gründe eher dagegen sprechen. Kees van Wonderen bezeichnet sich ja auch immer selbst als Prozesstrainer und will, dass das weiter geht. Doch, als Zauberer. Oder als Zauberer, ja. Ich fände es da auch wieder verheerend, wenn man jetzt im Sommer sagt, ja, wir schmeißen dich raus. Weil eigentlich hat man auch kein Argument, warum man van Wonderen rausschmeißt. Also, sein Punkteschnitt ist ähnlich wie Gerards. Eigentlich haben jetzt alle gesehen, es lag nicht an Gerards, sondern es liegt am Kader, an der Kader-Zusammenstellung, dass es nicht mehr drin ist. Van Wonderen braucht Zeit. Das hat er bei seinen anderen Stationen auch gezeigt, gerade bei den Go-Ahead-Eagles. Ist er ja auch, glaube ich, erst in der zweiten Saison da mit denen aufgestiegen. Also, warum sollte man nicht in die Saison 25, 26 gehen, mit van Wonderen? Und ich meine, es wäre jetzt auch nicht das unschalkeligste Ding, ihn dann halt 25, 26 nach neun Spieltagen rauszuschmeißen.
Das hast du schön gesagt, aber was ja auch zur Geschichte dazu gehört. Van Wonderen war, glaube ich, da gerade zu dem Zeitpunkt drei Monate da. Da hat er selber seinen Rücktritt angeboten im Dezember, ich glaube, vorm Paderborn-Spiel, wenn ich das so richtig gehört habe. Das hat man dann ja sehr wild gewonnen am Ende des Tages. Es stand wohl damals auch schon Funkel als Nachfolger bereit. Natürlich, der ewige Friedhelm Funkel wäre er sonst.
Man kommt total schnell vom Krefelder Tennisplatz nach Gelsenkirchen. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem für Friedhelm. Das ist perfekt.
Das ist wirklich– Halle sind Liga ist so ein Meme. Das ist wirklich unfassbar. Aber es stand wohl eben schon bereit. Schalke wollte es damals nicht akzeptieren. Es gab dann damals eben auch einen sehr guten Dezember, möchte ich fast sagen. Also mit Siegen gegen Paderborn, gegen Elvesberg und entschieden gegen Düsseldorf. Und generell finde ich schon, dass man– also rein ergebnistechnisch– man gewinnt meistens die Spiele gegen die Konkurrenz unten drin, was ja erstmal wichtig ist, wenn du dich aus diesem Abstiegskampf verabschieden willst. Du bist jetzt gerade in diesem, ich möchte es freundlich sagen, Grau- und Maus-Alltag angekommen, was ja per se trotzdem trotz allem, was Schalke natürlich jetzt auch durchgemacht hat, ja jetzt auch per se nicht so schlecht ist. Aber ich lese wirklich, du brauchst ja wirklich nur KSVW und googeln und es erscheint innerhalb von zwei Minuten acht Artikel darüber, so hier neun Punkte spielen, also beziehungsweise die nächsten drei Partien gegen, du hast es angesprochen, Viert und Ulm und dann eben gegen Regensburg, da sollen neun Punkte her. Also ich frage mich halt da so ein bisschen, solche Gerüchte, die werden ja auch von irgend wem in die, also vereinsnah in die Welt gesetzt, dass dieses, dieser Rücktritt oder Gerücht oder die Tatsache auf einmal Ende Januar, Anfang Februar gestreut wurde, das hat ja per se meistens leider auch einfach Gründe, ich glaube dafür sind wir alle zu lange im Fußball unterwegs. Warum, denkst du, macht man sich denn vereinseitig, also da auch diesen Kasten irgendwie wieder auf, dieses Thema wieder auf?
Also ich würde gerne einmal vorwegstellen, ich fand es menschlich groß von von Wunderern, dass er quasi direkt gesagt hat, ja, ich habe tatsächlich den Rücktritt angeboten, also als diese ganze Nummer aufgekommen ist, dass er da nicht irgendwie drum herum gedruckst hat, sondern gesagt hat, ja, weil ich hatte das Gefühl, ich zünde hier nicht, wie ich es mir in den ersten Wochen gewünscht habe und dann hat die Mannschaft ein Stück weit für mich geantwortet und jetzt glaube ich daran, dass ich eben seinen vielbeschworenen Prozess hier weiterführen kann. Ich glaube, Schalke ist halt ein großer Verein mit vielen Strömungen und entsprechend viele Leute wollen da mitreden. Entsprechend lancieren dann halt die eine oder anderen Parteien Geschichten, sei es jetzt Raoul, wo ich auch dann Manga, beziehungsweise ich weiß nicht, ob es Manga war am Ende tatsächlich, aber irgendjemand hat ja dann auch bestätigt, ja, man sei nach Madrid gereist und habe mit Raoul gesprochen, wo ich mir denke, du hast einen Trainer zu Hause sitzen, warum machst du dir die Baustelle auf? Also du fliegst ja nicht nur nach Madrid und sprichst mit Raoul über die spanische Sonne, sondern willst ja irgendwie auch über Schalke gehen und über ihn als Trainer und in so einer Situation, das stärken natürlich Van Wonderen Rücken auch nicht. Ich glaube, Van Wonderen ist schon auch am hadern, ich glaube, er hat sich das alles nicht so verzweckt vorgestellt, aber ich glaube auch, er ist im positiven Sinne dann auch bei sich und denkt, na ja, ich kann nur das beeinflussen, was ich beeinflussen kann und was passiert, passiert. Ich glaube, Van Wonderen wäre nicht so ein Typ, der sollte jetzt gehen müssen, aus welchen Gründen auch immer gegen den Verein schießt, was ja da Geraz vor einigen Monaten gemacht hat, in mehreren belgischen Zeitungen. Also sehr aktiv nach vorne gegangen ist und eine kleine, private Schmutzkampagne gegen den Verein gefahren hat. Weil du einfach gesehen hast, der Typ hat sich so auf den Schlips getreten, gefühlt mit der ganzen Manga-Geschichte und so. Der hat sich da irgendwie eine Karrieremöglichkeit mit Schalke verbaut gesehen gehabt. Und so schätze ich Van Wonderen nicht ein. Aber ja, die Frage, wer jetzt diese ganze Unruhe streut, kann ich dir so klar nicht beantworten. Weil auf der einen Seite stellt sich gerade Jürgen Mölder öffentlich vor Van Wonderen, Tilmann, der jetzt in letzter Zeit sich ein bisschen weniger zum Sportlichen geäußert hat. Hat aber auch zumindest nicht rumgedruckt, sondern hat gesagt, Kees Van Wonderen ist unser Trainer. Was natürlich bei Schalke auch immer reinspielt, sind die großen Sponsoren, wo wir sicherlich gleich auch noch mal zu sprechen kommen. Und die haben natürlich auch ihre ganz eigenen Visionen und Ideen für den Verein. Und gerade Personen mit Geld denken auch, dass sie dann direkt Einfluss haben qua ihres Kontostandes. Und gerade bei Schalke gibt es eben ausreichend Kanäle, wo Leute mal dem einen oder anderen Funktionär was rein, so fliehen, und der wiederum guten Draht zu verschiedenen Boulevard-Zeitungen hat, die natürlich auch ihre Seiten füllen müssen und die nehmen das dann dankend an. Aber ja, unterm Strich ist es im Moment eine Gemengelage, wo man nicht weiß, wer steht noch hinter wem, wer ist mit wem noch grün, wer wird überhaupt im Sommer noch da sein. Ich meine, Matthias Tillmann ist ja auch jetzt in den vergangenen Wochen wieder so ein bisschen ins Wackeln geraten, auch unter anderem, weil die Genossenschaft, über die wir sicherlich gleich sprechen, nicht so den raketenmäßigen Start hingelegt hat, er da kommunikativ ordentlich zurückrudern musste. Wenn die ganze Geschichte mit Ben Wanga jetzt im Sommer wirklich irgendwie auseinandergehen sollte, dann wird Tillmann auch sehr viel weniger Kredit haben, wobei er aber natürlich immer noch mit seinem alten Buddy, Axel Hefals, Aufsichtsratvorsitzenden ein sehr gutes Schutzschild hat. Also, ja, es ist dieses Meme mit den roten Linien. Es ist ein einziges Schlachtfeld auf Schalke. Und das ist halt auf der einen Seite Unterhaltung pur, aber auf der anderen Seite auch wirklich nicht gut für den Blutdruck, wenn man wirklich was an dem Verein gefunden hat.
Ja, dann lass uns doch tatsächlich fast schon einmal auf die Genossenschaft gucken. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass das viele mitbekommen haben, dass es seit dem 22. Januar ausschließlich Mitgliedern des Vereins sowie, glaube ich, juristischen Personen– heißt es richtig– möglich, Anteile an der Aufschalke-EG zu zeichnen. Also, das ist zum Beispiel auch der große Unterschied zur Genossenschaft bei St. Pauli. Da ist es ja auch außerhalb von dem Mitgliedsstamm eben möglich, hat sicherlich auch was mit der hohen Anzahl von Mitgliedern zu tun, die der Verein hat. Und es ist eben so, bisher wurden insgesamt 22.842 Anteile seit dem 26. Januar gezeichnet und insgesamt sind 190.400, also angelegt an das Gründungsdatum 1904, in der ersten Phase des Projekts verfügbar und es funktioniert eben so, dass die Schalker verkaufen quasi eben diese Genossenschaftsanteile für 250 Euro pro Stück, zuzüglich so einer Registrierungsgebühr von 75 Euro und dann soll eben das eingenommene Geld dafür genutzt werden, Stadionanteile zurückzukaufen, die eben bei Dritten liegen und eben auch so einen eigenen Kapital einfach aufzubauen. Also ich glaube…
Wobei ich dich da an einer Stelle kurz korrigieren würde, also man kauft Stadionanteile vom Verein zurück, also die IG kauft Anteile vom Verein, was eigentlich bedeutet, die Mitglieder kaufen sich selbst ihre Anteile ab, weil dadurch, dass der Verein ja quasi Besitzer des Stadions ist und der Verein Mitglieder geführt ist, sind die Mitglieder ja schon im Besitz des Stadions. Also es ist… Man verkauft eigentlich nur Luft, heiße Luft und Folklore, aber wo, wenn nicht auf Schalke?
Ja, und natürlich eben auch, ich glaube schon, dass man am Ende dann schon weiß, Folklore und halt die Sicherheit, dass der Verein vielleicht auch existiert bleibt. Also muss man ja auch einfach ganz krass zu sagen. Also ich meine, ich glaube, die Wichtigkeit dieses Projekts wäre nochmal anders, wenn man jetzt doch irgendwie um die 3. Liga noch hätte fürchten müssen, sage ich mal so. Es ist natürlich, wenn ich es richtig gelesen habe, waren alleine mit Abschluss, also Jahresabschluss quasi 2023, musste man irgendwie 16 Millionen Zins- und Tilgungen zahlen. Das ist natürlich sehr, sehr viel Geld. Vor allem für halt einen Zweitligisten. Das ist einfach so. Wir haben es eben einmal schon im Vorbericht gesagt, die letzten Zahlen sind von Mitte Februar, glaube ich. Man wollte das, glaube ich, immer nach außen kommunizieren zu den Heimspielen.
Na ja, Tillmann hat gesagt, er möchte es nicht gezwungenermaßen bei jedem Heimspiel. Er hat formuliert, sie möchten es immer im Vorlauf der Heimspiele verkünden, wenn es was zu verkünden gibt. Und was für mich bedeutet, wenn man seit einem Monat nichts mehr bei Heimspielen verkündet hat, wird sich an dem aktuellen Stand von 6,2 Millionen generierten Euro nicht so viel getan haben, weil davor hat man halt in zwei Wochen erst einmal die 3 Millionen, die 5 Millionen, jetzt die 6,2 Millionen kommuniziert. Und jetzt ist halt seit vier Wochen, ist man so ein bisschen in der Schwebe. Es wurde ja kommuniziert, dass man bis zum 19.04., also auch da angelehnt an 1904, ans Gündungsjahr, bis dahin wollte man minimum 10 Millionen generieren. Aber auch, weil du jetzt von die 16 Millionen Tilgungslast die jährlich anfällt, die man auf jeden Fall quasi für die verschiedenen Darlehen und so weiter und so fort zahlen muss, dass die einfach weiterlaufen, dass der Verein auch weiter existieren bleibt, damit eben Spielergehälter, Mitarbeitergehälter und so weiter überhaupt gezahlt werden können. Selbst wenn du die 10 Millionen jetzt einnimmst bis zum 19.04., das ist ja eine einmalige Einnahme zunächst einmal, heißt, du hast nicht mal die Tilgungssumme eines Jahres dann eingenommen. Also das ist schon Wahnsinn, wenn man sich das überlegt, dass also diese ganze Million von Euro, die jetzt generiert werden, per se erstmal für andere eingenommen werden oder generell auch, dass der FC Schalke 04 jedes Jahr erstmal so plus minus 15 Millionen irgendwo her generieren muss, um das Banken und anderen Gläubige dann zahlen zu können, damit die weiter sagen können, alles klar, wir bedienen weiter eure Darlehenkredite ETC. Also das ist schon wirklich bemerkenswert, wie dünn sozusagen die Kasse oder wie leer die Kassen auf Schalke sind und wie pfiffig dann eben durchaus clevere Köpfchen, studierte Betriebswirtschaftler, wie Tillmann da dann werden, wie kreativ, um irgendwie neues Geld zu generieren. Weil klar, ich habe es schon gesagt, auf Schalke kannst du den Leuten wahrscheinlich auch Luft verkaufen. Jede Sonderedition, die du rausschmeißt, ist innerhalb von Minuten, von Stunden ausverkauft. Aber das kannst du ja auch nicht nonstop machen. Und selbst, wenn du irgendwie ein limitiertes Trikot raushaust, da generierst du ja auch nicht 10 Millionen mit. Weil so limitiert kann es ja dann nicht sein, wenn man damit irgendwie 10 Millionen generiert. Also ich finde diese Genossenschaftsidee grundsätzlich gut, dass man sagt, wir schweißen diese Genossenschaft von Schalke-Fans noch mehr zusammen, indem wir dem Ganzen auch die Namengenossenschaft geben. Und wir geben euch noch eine Möglichkeit von Mitspracherecht. Weil, wenn du Mitglied in der Genossenschaft bist, hast du ja auch eine Stimme in der Hauptversammlung der Genossenschaft. Wobei da auch die Frage ist, was wird am Ende in so einer Hauptversammlung besprochen? Also was mich zum Beispiel interessieren würde, aktuell oder in der aktuellen Saison hat der FC Schalke 04 ja die Arena vermietet gehabt an Schachtier Donitz, damit die im Exil ihre Champions League-Spiele austragen können. Wenn die Genossenschaft jetzt genügend Anteile zurückkauft, quasi vom Stammverein, und damit dann Mitsprache recht hat an der Nutzung des Stadions, was ist, wenn sich dann so eine Gruppe formiert und sagt, wir stimmen jetzt aber in der Hauptversammlung dagegen, dass Schachtier die Arena nutzt oder dass die Arena nicht mehr für Konzerte genutzt wird? Ich meine, es gibt ja allerlei Sachen, die die Leute irgendwie aufstößen können. Das wäre dann wiederum kontraproduktiv, weil allein die Vermietung der Arena an Schachtier Donetsk hat in dieser Saison, glaube ich, 2 Millionen reingespült. Und da ist, glaube ich, nicht mal das Catering, was an den Spieltagen über das Schalke-eigene Catering rausgegeben wurde. Deren Einnahmen sind dann noch nicht mal eingerechnet. Also ja, es ist cool, dass Schalke noch mal eine Möglichkeit der Mitsprache damit schafft. Aber man macht sich natürlich auch ein bisschen Baustellen damit auf, weil die Arena ist halt das Prunkstück und ist die Kronjuwele des Vereins. Ich meine, deswegen hat der Verein ja diese ganzen Schulden und das negative Eigenkapital, weil man die Arena immer noch abbezahlt und immer noch quasi den Zins und den Zinseszins des Stadionbaus Anfang der 2000 abbezahlt. Aber genauso lebenserhaltend ist sie eben allein als Event-Location, sei es Biathlon oder Konzerte und so weiter. Also da komplett so einer großen, anonymen Masse, in Anführungszeichen, da die Mitsprache zu geben, macht mich auch so ein bisschen kribbelig, hibbelig, weil man eben nicht weiß, was für komische Allienzen sich dann vielleicht für so eine Hauptversammlung zusammensetzen.
Zwei Nahfragen dazu. Erstens, wie bewertest du denn, dass per se erst mal nur Mitglieder dadurch angesprochen werden? Also dass man das wirklich darauf fokussiert?
Das finde ich erstmal grundsätzlich gut, weil Schalke das ja auch immer vor sich hin trägt, dass man Mitglied, Mitgliedergeführter Verein ist, dass die Mitglieder wirklich nur was zu sagen haben, dass eine Schalke-Mitgliedschaft etwas bedeutet. Da finde ich es gut, dass man sagt, du solltest schon Mitglied sein, wenn du hier auch noch über das Stadium mitbestimmen möchtest. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass Unternehmen ausgeschlossen sind, also juristische Personen. Und da ist halt für mich die Krux, weil wenn man sich anschaut mit Hagedorn und Tönnies, der immer noch mit seiner Marke Böcklunder unter den Top 5 Sponsoren auf Schalkes, haben zwei Partner von Schalke öffentlich der Genossenschaftsidee in der Absage geteilt. Schalke wirbt ja ganz offensiv, damit das Unternehmen reinkommt und eben nicht nur einen Anteil, wie vielleicht ich, für 250 Euro zeichnet einfach, um dann zu sagen, hey, ich bin Stadion-Teilhaber, obwohl man das eigentlich schon vorher war, sondern man hat dann mannigfaltige Möglichkeiten, gib mal direkt 50.000 Euro oder mehr. Aber da muss man halt auch sagen, bietet Schalke den Unternehmen eigentlich auch nicht so viele Möglichkeiten. Also ich hatte mir mal durchgeguckt, was kriegt man so, wenn man Summe X bekommt. Und das fängt dann halt an bei einem gerahmten Schalke-Trick, wo ich mir denke, gut, wenn du Sponsor bist, kriegst du das wahrscheinlich sowieso jedes Jahr. Dann geht es über ein Stadionnachbau. Irgendwie, also ich weiß nicht aus einem 3D-Drucker oder wie auch immer, ist ja auch bummsegal, aber da denke ich mir auch so, ja toll, das stellt sich der Vorstandsvorsitzende auf den Schreibtisch, aber zahlt er dafür wirklich 10.000 Euro an Anteilen. Und dann soll es ein Schalker Business Network geben, wo ich mich aber auch frage, da muss es ja eine gewisse Anzahl von Unternehmen erst mal geben, die sagen, jo, da schließen wir uns zusammen, damit es für die nächste juristische Person, das nächste Unternehmen überhaupt attraktiv ist. Also wenn da nur drei Leute oder drei Unternehmen in diesem Netzwerk sind, und die sind vielleicht sogar alle aus Gelsenkirchen, oder sind eh alle schon Logenbesitzer auf Schalke, oder treffen sich ohnehin schon jeden Samstag im blauen Salon, was ist dann der Zweck des Business-Metzwerkes? Also das ist ja kein Mehrwert dann für ein Unternehmen. Und ich glaube, das haben eben die Unternehmen Hagedorn und Tönnies auch so empfunden, dass der Mehrwert einer Investition nicht da ist. Und gerade solche Personen kriegst du dann halt im letzten Instanz nicht mehr mit Vollklohe, wenn es dann halt nicht mehr um 250 Euro, sondern vielleicht auch um 250.000 oder 25.000 Euro, je nachdem, geht. Weil solche Personen sind schon mit ihren eigenen Logen vertreten, sind schon überall sichtbar in und um die Arena. Also die haben auch nichts davon, dass an diesem Förderturm, der da jetzt gebaut werden soll im Stadionumfeld, eine Plakette von denen dran ist. Also ich glaube, klar, das sind Personen, die gerne ihr Ego gestreichelt bekommen, aber wie gesagt, der Name oder der Name ihres Unternehmens ist schon viel größer und viel sichtbarer in der Arena zu sehen. Die brauchen das nicht, so eine Plakette.
Ja, aber das ist nämlich das Ding, also das kann auch sein, ich fand da die Infos zu tatsächlich auch sehr, sehr schwameg, die man so nachlesen konnte. Weil ich habe, wenn ich das nämlich auch richtig nachgelesen habe, ist, dass die ja auch in irgendeiner Weise schon irgendwie Mitglied, also in Anführungszeichen Mitglied des Vereins sein müssen. Und das ist natürlich, also wenn du neue, vielleicht auch eben was du eben sagst, neue Unternehmen auch aus der Region ansprechen willst, die vielleicht vorher noch nicht im Sponsoring und die dann ja irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, eine Bande kriegen, eine, weiß ich nicht, Werbung auf einer Anzeigetafel, ein Trikotsponsor, also die 80.000 Möglichkeiten, die es ja vom Makro bis Großsponsorin gibt, haben. Also wie denkst du, dass du denen da die Sichtbarkeit gibst? Also glaubt man wirklich, dass das dann irgendwie so eine Sache wird, dass man restliche Mitglieder zusammenschweißt da und da eben die Markensichtbarkeit erhöht und so? Also das geht dann natürlich auch tief ins Sponsoring rein, beziehungsweise in das Verständnis von Genossenschaft. Aber ich glaube, weil es ist ja auch egal per se, wie hoch dieser Anteilserwerb ist, aber sie kriegen ja, glaube ich, trotzdem nur eine Stimme in dieser Genossenschaft.
Genau, und das ist ja auch prinzipiell sehr gut, weil du eben dadurch nicht sozusagen so ein Oligarchentum durch die Hintertür ermöglicht, dass eben jetzt ein Großsponsor sagt, ich bin bisher ein Großsponsor, aber jetzt putter ich mal ein paar Hunderttausend in die Genossenschaft und kaufe mich quasi dadurch in den Verein ein. Das ist gut gelöst. Aber ja, wie gesagt, ich glaube, die Personen, Unternehmen, die eh schon im Umfeld von Schalke tätig sind, sehen eben nicht den Sinn darin, jetzt noch in der Genossenschaft groß zu investieren. Das ist halt, glaube ich, wirklich eine Angelegenheit, die vor allem Fans anspricht, die eben sich die 250 Euro gut leisten können. Die denken, die tun mir nicht weh jetzt am Ende des Monats. Da gab es ja auch beispielsweise einen tollen Beitrag vom WDR, der einfach mal durch Gelsenkirchen gestapft ist und verschiedene Personen angesprochen hat. Was haltet ihr denn von der Genossenschaft? Da haben wirklich viele Leute gesagt, ich gebe mein letztes Hemd für den FC Schalke 04, aber ich war auch schon seit Jahren nicht mehr in der Arena, weil ich es mir nicht leisten kann. Und die 250 Euro kann ich mir jetzt recht nicht leisten. Und da vermisse ich dann halt auch schon wieder so ein bisschen diese Rückbesinnung des Vereins auf seine Wurzeln. Weil ja, den Wurzeln ist ja schon lange entwachsen, aber du sprichst ja nicht wirklich den Gelsenkirchener Nachfolger von Asi Erich an, sondern du gehst schon auf gut situierte Leute. Und auch wenn du die anschaust an so einem Spieltag, wenn du auf dem Weg hoch das Berger Feld bist, da kommen relativ wenige Leute noch mit der Burgestra an, also mit der Straßenbahn, sondern da sind eher eben Autokennzeichen aus aller Herren Landkreise unterwegs. Und das merkst du dann halt auch im Stadion. Also ich glaube, der Anteil von nicht gelsen Kirchen und nicht Ruhrportlern liegt vielleicht bei 70, 80 Prozent. Das ist per se eben nicht schlecht, werde ich gesagt, weil der Verein einfach so groß ist und so groß gewachsen ist. Aber die Gemeinschaft und die Genossenschaft. Aber die Gemeinschaft Schalke und die Genossenschaft Schalke gehen da nicht unbedingt einher, weil dieser Grundgedanke, gelsen Kirchen, Fußballverein wird jetzt auch in der Genossenschaft nicht irgendwie groß abgedeckt. Und ich glaube, das ist auch gar nicht das Ziel, sondern das Ziel ist, mit einer pfiffigen Idee so viel Geld wie möglich rauszuholen, um sich ein bisschen Luft zum Verschnaufen zu erkaufen. Wobei ich da aber auch gesagt habe, ich gebe dem Verein gerne ein bisschen Geld, weil ich es kann. Aber die Frage ist eher, möchte ich dem aktuellen Management das Geld geben? Und diese Frage habe ich auch von vielen Personen aus meinem Umfeld, aus dem Schalker Fan-Umfeld gehört. Also ja, Geld geben, damit der Verein weiter erhalten bleibt und dass wir weiter alle zwei Wochen hinkilgern können. Aber will man eben diesen Personen das Geld in die Hand geben? Sieht man da wirklich eine Vision, was mit dem Geld gemacht wird? Weil du hattest es ja gesagt, Eva, das ist alles so ein bisschen schwammig. Also man sagt, man möchte diese Anteile zurückkaufen und dadurch die Tilgungslast mindern. Und wenn es super läuft, dann will man auch in die Infrastruktur investieren. Aber was genau da geplant sein könnte, ist halt so ein bisschen in der Schwebe. Oder wann es geplant sein könnte. Und das ist halt dann auch so ein bisschen Stand heute. Ich meine, die ganze Kampagne läuft jetzt auch schon ein paar Wochen. Es ist so ein bisschen frustrierend, dass man da... Ich meine, 6 Millionen sind viel. Aber dass man da jetzt so ein bisschen... Es ist halt weder Fisch noch Fleisch. Man hat so ein bisschen Geld eingenommen, aber halt auch kein Geld, was jetzt irgendwie kriegsentscheidend oder spielentscheidend sein wird.
Vor allem nicht in der Grand Scheme. Weil natürlich viele dann noch dran denken, mit meinem Geld, da kann man dann den nächsten Top-Schürmer verpflichten oder so, aber das ist ja wirklich dann eher die 800. Stelle, die dann bedacht werden kann.
Wobei auch das ja, also dieses Narrativ wurde ja auch von der Vereinsführung durchaus genährt. Also Tillmann hat immer gesagt, wenn jetzt 50 Millionen, was das Maximum wäre, mit dieser ersten Phase von 190.400 Anteilen. Oder wenn wir die 50 Millionen einnehmen, dann ändert sich die Welt auf Schalke. Dann können wir auch richtig in den Kader investieren. Auch schon bei 20 Millionen könnten wir richtige Topspieler verpflichten. Wo ich mir halt auch denke, das kann ja gut sein. Aber warum pflanzst du das den Leuten so in den Kopf? Also keiner wird jetzt die 6 Millionen sehen und denken, gutes Geld, die werden da sicherlich was draus machen. Alle werden sehen, 6 Millionen, also scheiß auf die 20 Millionen, wir können auch schon für 6 Millionen was mit dem Kader machen. Aber eigentlich ist das ja nicht der Plan, dass man so kurzfristig denkt, sondern diese ganze Genossenschaft ist darauf ausgelegt, dass man auf mittelfristige Sicht und auf langfristige Sicht den Stammverein stärkt, damit er grundsätzlich mehr Kapazitäten monetär hat, um sich nachhaltig zu verstärken oder nachhaltig sportlich aufzustellen. Also es soll keine einmalige Sache sein, wir nehmen 6 Millionen an, die ballern wir sofort im Sommer raus. Aber durch eben solche Aussagen wie von Tillmann und gerade in der heutigen Zeit verkürzt, ein TikTok stellt so da, das zweite schon so und das dritte ist dann halt, ja die 6 Millionen landen im Kader. Das hast du ja auch nicht mehr eingefangen. Machst du es dir halt selbst ein bisschen schwer.
Ja, wir haben enorm überzogen mit der Zeit und ich bedanke mich trotzdem recht herzlich, dass ihr beide dabei wart. Ich würde es aber deshalb an der Stelle jetzt auch tatsächlich hier ein bisschen karten, weil wir könnten da sicherlich noch sehr lange drüber reden, weil ich es auch einfach super interessant finde über also, weil wir natürlich da auch immer über das Thema reden, 50 plus 1 und inwieweit wird es überhaupt in den 36 Profiklubs der DFL gelebt, aber wie nachhaltig sind die einzelnen Modelle mit GmbH und KUK AG und was auch noch alles, KGAA etc. überhaupt, das ist tatsächlich sehr, sehr spannend. Mal sehen, vielleicht müssen wir dann Max einfach nochmal bequatschen, dass er da nochmal ein sehr, sehr ausführliches Trainingsgespräch macht, aber ich bedanke mich ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz herzlich bei meinen beiden Gästen. Das allererstes bei Jan. Jan, schön, dass du nach fünf Jahren auch ohne Corona mal wieder im Rasenfunk dabei warst.
Es war mir eine sehr große Freude.
Das freut mich auf jeden Fall und dann natürlich auch lieben, lieben Dank an Dominik. Schön, dass du uns etwas zur Schalke sportlich als auch finanziell erklärt hast. Danke, dass du wieder dabei warst.
Danke, immer wieder gerne.
So, und dann, wie versprochen, hört ihr mich jetzt erstmal nicht so schnell wieder, sondern der Marc übernimmt zumindest schon mal die nächste Folge. Da werde ich mich nämlich im DFB-Bokal-Halbfinal-Studel befinden und deshalb nicht hier sitzen. Habt viel Spaß mit der Länderspielpause und dann hören wir uns in zwei Wochen hier wieder. Tschüss.
Ciao.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank.
Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.